[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale et nous sommes le mercredi 16
février au sommaire aujourd'hui
hectares est le plus grand qu'on puisse
agricole il est yvelinois implantée à
lévis un nom il ouvre progressivement
ses portes depuis le mois de septembre
la présentation du projet dans ce
journal focus sur l'accélérateur de
start up le rendez vous était donné ce
matin hier soir une première réunion
publique en soutien à eric zemmour a
lieu dans les yvelines sur place les
porte parole du candidat objectif du
parti reconquête faire barrage à la
république en marche retour sur la
soirée et puis l approche de salon de
l'agriculture nous vous emmenons
découvrir les producteurs et yves binois
pour ce deuxième volet rencontre avec
lauriane et manon élèves à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet elles seront
sur place pour participer à la finale
nationale des jeunes bergers et puis
également dans cette édition suite de
notre dossier de la semaine consacrée au
marché blinois aujourd'hui nous
emmèneront au coeur du marché de
mantes-la-jolie
[Musique]
et on débute ce journal avec cette
nouvelle étape d'allègement des
restrictions à sanitaires un point sur
ce qui change ce mercredi à 16 février
elle c'est le retour des concerts debout
les discothèques peuvent également
rouvrir leurs portes dans le respect du
protocole sanitaire bien sûr côté
consommation mais bien elle est de
nouveau permise dans les lieux
accueillant du public notamment
culturels sportifs et dans les
transports et puis la consommation
debout dans les bars et les restaurants
est elle aussi autorisé
et on passe dans le domaine de
l'agriculture avec ha c'est le plus
grand campus agricoles du monde il est
implanté à lévis un nom sur 600 hectares
il a été créé par audrey bourolleau et
xavier niel et c'est un centre de
formation de nombreux projets
fleurissent depuis la rentrée on
reviendra dans quelques instants sur
l'accélérateur de start up notamment
mais juste avant on va parler plus
globalement de ce campus et c'est avec
vous francis napper bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes un le directeur d'hectares pourquoi
ce campus est sorti de terre 1 c'est le
cas de le dire en quoi c'est un besoin
dans le domaine de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui de disposer d'un centre de
formation comme hectares ont fait
l'écart apporte des solutions aux
différents défis que nous avons
à adresser dans les années qui viennent
en ce qui concerne l'agriculture et
surtout les acteurs de l'agriculture au
global on a des défis climatiques on a
des défis de production alimentaire
durable et on a des défis aussi de
changement de génération des
agriculteurs et avoir à la fois un
centre un campus nous on l'appelle de
formation et
d'accélération de solutions pour les
agriculteurs nous paraît être le rendez
vous en tout cas le
lieu où se cristallisent d'une certaine
manière des solutions intéressantes
qu'on souhaite pas en avant et justement
les missions du campus d'hectares c'est
ça c'est trouver des nouvelles solutions
être innovants ont fait de deux manières
donc à la fois côté ferme qui on est
aussi une femme comme vous l'avez dit de
600 hectares et on innove sur cette
ferme on essaye de proposer des
nouvelles solutions qui soient alors
acceptable socialement c'est à dire sur
la pénibilité sur l'organisation du
travail sur les différents ateliers coup
qu'on mène et puis côté
c'est à dire comment est ce qu'on
accompagne des startups à grandir sur
des sujets des productions agricoles qui
soit durable pour la tête et il porte
des vrais aide aux agriculteurs qui en
ont besoin et justement à cet
accompagnement on va en parler puisque
ce 16 février un plusieurs startups
sélectionnées par hectare à des rendez
vous sur le campus il s'est associé le
campus à l'incubateur hec paris pour
accompagner à c'est donc aux entreprises
à se développer a évolué le but donc
c'est pensé écrit l'agriculture de
demain vous en avez parlé je vous
propose de découvrir ce reportage de
mathilde francou et puis on en parle
juste après avec vous implanté dans le
parc régional naturel de la haute vallée
de chevreuse hectares présente le plus
grand campus agricoles du monde créé par
audrey bourolleau et xavier niel patron
de free le centre de formation a lancé
en octobre 2021 son accélérateur de
start up après 135 candidature et 25
présélection onze entreprises ont été
choisies un objectif commun grandir et
évoluer ensemble pour bâtir
l'agriculture de demain en amont la
première marque d' alternative à la
viande sans ingrédient ultra transformé
donc ça veut dire que base de vrais
ingrédients qu'on pourrait trouver dans
sa cuisine globalement nous ce qu'on
veut faire c'est à partir du moment où
il récolte son produit jusqu'à la
facturation de ce produit on intervient
sur cette chaîne de l'accélérateur de
start-up s'articule autour de quatre
domaines
l'alimentation l'agriculture
régénératrice lindor farming et la
grille tech qui fait référence à la
robotisation l intelligence artificielle
le kobo tout il aussi la collaboration
entre l'homme et la machine est le but
c'est d'avoir de la technologie
embarquée qui soit très sophistiqué mais
que l' usage soit extrêmement simple et
donc on a cherché à faire de cet outil
une plateforme vraiment polyvalente pour
que la personne gagne un maximum de
temps dans le travail et qu'elle puisse
l'utiliser à beaucoup d' usage différent
donc du semis à la plantation au
désherbage à la récolte les onze
start-up vont bénéficier du double
réseau hec paris et hectares soit 30
mentor et 500 experts elles vont
également pouvoir profiter d'un espace
de travail de 2000 m² ainsi que de 50 ha
d'expérimentation je trouve qu'ils sont
un réseau non seulement de mentors qui
peuvent nous accompagner nous aider à
revenir passer à l'échelle et atteindre
ses 2500 producteurs à la fin de l'année
le partage d'un réseau mais aussi des
mêmes valeurs autour de l'environnement
et le souhait d'une agriculture plus
durable c'est génial parce que ha vient
rassembler des gens avec des compétences
extrêmement fortes dans le domaine de
l'agroalimentaire
les mettre autour de la table pour
partager une vision commune de
l'agriculture durable l'accélérateur a
pour objectif final de permettre le
développement de 80 start up en deux ans
dans le secteur agricole
on le disait un du coup c'est le plus
grand campus agricoles du monde il n'y a
donc pas que l'accélérateur dont on
vient de voir les images d'oncle
accélérateur de start up qu'est ce qu'on
peut trouver d'autres finalement sur
place concrètement au delà de
l'accélérateur hectares propose deux
autres projets qui font sens par rapport
à la thèse d'état le premier qui est de
la formation pour accompagner des
entrepreneurs agricoles dans le sens où
ce sont des personnes qui vont changer
de vie et s'installer en agriculture
reprendre une ferme où on crée une
exploitation agricole
ça on le fait sur un programme soit de
cinq semaines très intenses très proche
de l'installation ou un programme de six
mois qui a un parcours plus longs et
plus consolidant sur sur le projet
qu'ont en tête donc ce pilier de
formation est un élément assez important
et on ajoute à ça le troisième pilier de
des activités des quartiers de la
sensibilisation notamment auprès des
publics scolaires et pour lesquelles on
a déjà reçu à 2 200 enfants des yvelines
sur site afin de les sensibiliser aux
enjeux de la biodiversité de notre
production alimentaire d angle d impact
sur la santé de notre alimentation
voilà on passe des journées avec ses
publics afin de leur apporter un petit
peu de connaissances et les éveiller à
prouver à ces enjeux et à la fin
peut-être
projeter une image professionnelle
possible pour ses enfants donc ceux qui
s'imaginent un jour eux mêmes devenir
acteur de cet écosystème
vous travaillez finalement aussi haut
sur le campus avec et des étudiants
notamment en informatique vous
travaillez également avec eux il ya des
stagiaires un voulzy on sensibilise ya
des agriculteurs des entrepreneurs
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est aussi de
créer peut-être un réseau de mettre en
lien toutes ses compétences se faire
faire ces rencontres finalement en fait
la valeur d'avoir des personnes
complémentaires sur un même site c'est
de créer un écosystème et on l'a vu
aujourd'hui dans la présentation
notre programme d'accélération on avait
effectivement dans la même salle des
apprenants en code agritech on avait
des start up on avait des fonds
d'investissement on a tout un tas de
d'acteurs de l'écosystème hectares qui
se rend compte et ensemble qui ont qui
se donne envie d'avancer une question
d'énergie dans l'écosystème le fait
d'être ensemble au même endroit en fait
ça vous donne un élan formidable pour
continuer d'agir et de trouver des
solutions pour justement ces défis qui
sont juste devant de rester en lien
c'est important le campus finalement
ouvert progressivement depuis la rentrée
quelles sont les prochaines étapes pour
tout caler les prochains projets pour le
cantus ha alors on a plein d'idées
évidemment donc on essaye que ces idées
soient ancrés et réalisables et qu'elle
ait un impact on arrive à mesure et donc
en ayant déjà déjà en formation des
start up a accéléré il ya déjà beaucoup
de choses il ya sur la partie ferme
aussi où on a évidemment beaucoup
d'idées beaucoup de l'expérimentation en
cours et le l'idée de ce qu'on
expérimente sur sur la ferme c'est de
pouvoir le transmettre c'est là où on
fait les liens avec l'écosystème c'est
ce qu'on fait sur la ferme devient de la
matière intéressante pour nos apprenants
on a une vraie envie de transmettre en
fait ce que nous on a appris sur nos
ateliers agricoles aux futurs
agriculteurs qui passeront par les mêmes
on va dire chemin que ce qu on a
emprunté donc donc un des enjeux à court
terme c'est de documenter ce qu'on a
rencontrés sur l'expérience pour nous on
a eu deux des ateliers de la ferme afin
de pouvoir les transmettre notamment aux
apprenants montrant ce matin c'est
l'objectif principal
merci beaucoup francis n'a fait d'avoir
été avec nous et je le rappelle vous
êtes le directeur à d'hectares merci
[Musique]
en politique à présent ce mardi 15 ma
fait vriller pardon avait lieu la
première réunion publique dans les
yvelines c'était pour le parti
reconquête d'eric zemmour 450 personnes
étaient présentes à la maison la fille à
maisons-laffitte pour écouter les
paroles du parti notamment des
porte-paroles justement à l'occasion de
revenir sur le programme du candidat à
la présentielle 2022 le reportage de
céline charles regardez ils sont venus
nombreux à la salle malherbe de maisons
laffitte plusieurs générations ont fait
le déplacement des quatre coins des
yvelines pour venir écouter les
conférences de quatre personnalités
politiques tout porte parole d'eric
zemmour je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
france elle a besoin d'abord d'un homme
courageux et c'est précisément je dirais
ce qu'eric zemmour je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il a ce courage d'avoir
imposé un diagnostic lucide de proposer
des solutions qui sont claires qui sont
cohérentes on ne peut plus se contenter
du dut en même temps qu'elle nous a
tristement habitués emmanuel macron le
président de la république doit fixer
une vision il y en a une fixer un cap
d'action il y en a une veiller à ce que
les principales décisions qui sont de
son ressort soit mise en oeuvre
appliqués et suivi comme il convient
comme il veut comme le peuple français
l'a voulu une soirée pour mettre en
avant une union des droites pour le
parti reconquête comme le mouvement
conservateur via ou encore le cni p
l'objectif faire barrière à la
république en marche le mouvement
conservateur a été depuis sa fondation
attaché vraiment à une ligne politique
constante et cohérente et c'est ce qu'on
a trouvé chez eric zemmour stanislas
rigaud président de génération z le
mouvement jeunes de reconquête étaient
également présents pour représenter la
jeunesse je crois que cette élection
présidentielle ce n'est pas un candidat
de plus il va jouer s'est réellement là
de notre pays et nous entends jeunes en
tant que 16 30 ans c'est véritablement
notre avis elle qui va se mettre en
place le choix de société auquel nous
allons vivre doit être pris maintenant
2022 et ses proches ainsi tous les
jeunes à 1 s'intéressent elles sont
prises en ciel à l'essentiel sur listes
électorales et peut-être mars aller
voter et accents danse vous pouvez aller
voter une campagne qui s'accélère pour
le candidat qui dans la même journée à
gagner des points dans les sondages
selon une enquête harris interactive
pour challenge le candidat dépasse
maintenant valérie pécresse et se place
numéro trois derrière emmanuel macron et
marine le pen à moins de deux mois du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
c'est la suite de notre dossier de la
semaine consacrée au marché yvelinois
située à mantes la jolie le marché du
val fourré se tient les mardis et
vendredis après-midi et puis le dimanche
toute la journée sur place de nombreux
commerçants on trouve de tout des
produits alimentaires comme non
alimentaires avec elle des saveurs du
monde entier découverte de ce marché
avec nicolas d'amd regardez c'est l'un
des plus grands marchés d'île de france
le marché du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie compte 250 commerçants
ici on trouve de tout des fruits des
légumes du poisson de la viande des
vêtements et des accessoires un marché
très vivants avec une énorme ambiance et
on va tout de suite rencontré les
commerces
[Musique]
pascal moussard fait partie des
commerçants les plus anciens il vient
ici sur le marché du val fourré depuis
30 ans est un producteur de légumes et
il produit ses légumes à fontenay saint
pierre et il est avec nous bonjour
pascal bonjour alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire pourquoi vous avez
décidé au tout début depuis 30 ans
maintenant de vous installer ici sur le
marché du val fourré parce que c'est il
ya un gros volume de ventre et puis
c'est une époque on est beaucoup de
marchandises et puis du coup on
attendait sa place ici pour vous devez
avoir beaucoup d'histoires sur ce marché
on a rencontré beaucoup de monde et puis
neuf et connaissance il ya plusieurs
maintenant on a déjà connu koné bientôt
deux générations donc oui ce en quoi il
est particulier ce marché pour sa
convivialité bon déjà il ya les liens
qu'on volumes de vente et en plus c'est
un lieu de rencontre alors est-ce que
vous pouvez justement nous dire en quoi
consiste votre activité qu'est ce que
vous faites et qu'est ce qu'on peut
trouver chez vous à tous qui assure tape
déjà enfin tous les légumes racines
pommes de terre carottes
les oignons c'est pas des racines mais
de rutabaga n'avait topinambours tous
les légumes et puis battu falla sont nés
dont on est en hiver donc c'est chou
cardon et toute la gamme des potirons
vote or not
bleu de hongrie musqués et puis
ne peut pas facto et il se dit sur le
marché que vous êtes un peu le
thermomètre de ce marché dès le début de
la journée si vous avez du monde sait
que la journée va être exceptionnel
c'est vrai
il possible mais prayssac
16e peut être noté si on vous l'a dit
c'est que c'est quelque chose mais bon
je peux me vanter non plus
[Musique]
on trouve pas mieux ailleurs
parce que tout est moins cher et je
mélange et par rapport à l'ambiance
c'est plus familial et les royals et
mais magnifique et les gens sont
splendides
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et après avoir fait ses courses sur le
marché de mantes-la-jolie on peut aussi
se restaurer par exemple avec ses
spécialités algéroise et pour en parler
nous sommes avec yasmine santos bonjour
bonjour alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer ce qu'est en train de
faire s'il à votre maman est là en train
de faire d'une semaine c'est fait avec
de la semoule et de la farine ça vous
préparer ça à la maison et puis après
vous venez de faire on fait tout sur
place le tout tout tout sur place l'a
pas tout est fait sur place et puis il
ya d'autres eux aussi une petite
spécialité il ya des beignets
de poisson il ya de la galette kabyle
qui est fait elle même de semoule après
il ya des sardines né à des gâteaux ya
un peu de tout mais pas maintenant on va
passer à la dégustation qu'est-ce qu'on
peut déguster ici et là à faire goûter
pour faire un moment inoubliable c'est
la galette et la sardine y va à sardines
c'est ça c'est en fait la sardine
dénoyautées on enlève les arrête
les jours et on met de la farce à
l'intérieur sur l'autre on fait cuire à
guînes
[Musique]
merci explique parce que le thé à la
menthe c'est une tradition à lire et
bien voilà c'est ici que s'achève notre
excursion sur le marché du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie un marché qui se tient
le mardi et le vendredi de 12h30 à 18h30
et le dimanche de 10h à 18h et moi c'est
parti je vais commencer à manger parce
que ça a l'air très appétissants
[Musique]
il ouvrira ses portes dans dix jours
pour le deuxième épisode de notre série
les yvelines au salon de l'agriculture
nous sommes allés rencontrer lauriane
émanant est les deux jeunes yvelinoise
représenteront l'ile-de-france au salon
lors de la finale nationale du meilleur
jeune berger elles sont élèves à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet elle
se prépare aux épreuves théoriques et
pratiques elles devront faire face à 38
autres participants qui viennent de
partout en france le reportage de
mathilde de franco
[Musique]
annulé l'année dernière à cause du coc
vide 19 le salon international de
l'agriculture se tiendra cette année du
26 février au 6 mars plusieurs
producteurs yvelinois et seront présents
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
[Musique]
lauriane conseils émanant batista ont
été sélectionnés pour représenter l'île
de france lors de la finale nationale
des jeunes bergers au salon de
l'agriculture
les deux jeunes filles de 20 ans se
prépare aux épreuves théoriques et
pratiques élèves à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet elles peuvent compter sur
les conseils de leur formatrice mardi 15
février au programme parage des onglons
tutu la partie sombre de tomber ton pied
triage des brebis à l'aide d'un lecteur
électronique à cet âge ou sa passion
équipe et ça va nous mais piqué et
appréciation de l'état de santé d'une
brebis se vend on va regarder déjà sa
température pour comores
observations des dents des yeux des
pâtes tout y passe au niveau de ses
dents et dans la voix 8 ont converti a
pas trop de saleté s'ils sont pas trop
écartées
si l on n'a pas perdu puisque entre nos
deux anglo que ça soit plus claire
possible qu'ils aient pas d'odeur
lauriane et manon seront face à 38
autres participants venant de toute la
france très stressée vraiment pressé
mais hyper heureuse et et j'ai hâte mais
en même temps elle très performant un
peu stressé mais plutôt confiante parce
que c'est la troisième fois que je
participe du coup et j'ai envie de
vraiment prouver ce que je sais faire et
pire
rencontré beaucoup de professionnels du
milieu comme elle l'a dit ça peut être
très très cool est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'on est confiant je sais pas j'ai un
petit stress de formatrice derrière
quand même mais mais je leur fais
confiance parce que
elles sont au taquet on se prépare donc
il n'y a pas de raison que ça ne fasse
pas cette finale nationale du meilleur
jeune berger permet également aux
participants de découvrir le métier de
l'intérieur grâce aux échanges avec les
professionnels dans les prochaines
années plus d'un éleveur sur 2 partira à
la retraite
la filière ovine propose près de 10000
emplois dans la prochaine décennie
ce concours est donc l'occasion de
préparer la relève
les folates 78 a lancé son premier
winter tour yvelinois objectif de cette
fédération sportive multisports au
rendent accessibles les sports d'hiver
l'événement a débuté il y à un mois en
partenariat avec la ville de la verrière
et l'école régionale du premier degré de
la commune inauguration avait lieu ce
mercredi 16 février à 15h au programme
patinoire escalade ok ou encore bien
floues les activités s'adressent aux
enfants ils se poursuivent jusqu'au 4
mars participation sur inscription au 01
30 54 71 53 plus d'informations sur le
site du flep 78 point org et c'est la
fin de ce journal merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi dans un instant retrouver
votre 7,8 société présentée par mélanie
poké discussions ce soir autour des
logements sociaux et du taux de 25 %
auxquels doivent répondre les communes à
très vite sur tébéo 5,18
[Musique]